[Music]
you know you never know what can happen
in riverdale
that's the great thing about our show i
promise i'll eat some burgers okay
stop yelling at me on twitter this is a
reel that we saw she's severely
sizzle sizzle reel happy first comic-con
thank you i'm so excited for it so we're
an adaptation of the
very classic well-beloved all-american
series archie
comics um but this is a little bit
darker it's a grittier realistic take
this is your second year at comic-con
what was it like going from year one
where they hadn't seen the show and year
two where you guys even had
cosplay people dressing up as your
characters year one was really difficult
because
we had only shot the pilot so we didn't
even have any idea what season one would
look like
and all of the questions were about
season one so they'd be like so what is
in store for veronica
and we're like good question um why are
we here
here we are season three of riverdale
and you guys are now such a big deal
that you fill up hall h tomorrow how
does that make you feel
i mean it's like chill it's like
whatever though you know shout out to
the fans one word to describe
the beginning of season four yeah
we're scared i feel like we need to just
stay
there obviously like the girls aren't
sitting because we're women we're
sitting because our
feet are so bad like which is kind of
but the mystery is really the mystery is
really um
cool it's different from what we've done
in the first two seasons very cool oh
didn't you hear
oh her brother got murdered and then her
she got her dad killed him and then he
committed suicide potentially
so oh it's a little hard for her and now
her mom's severely burned
yeah but taking on the role of archie i
mean like what has that been like for
you
coming from new zealand it was kind of
um
it was really i was quite kind of
nervous because it was such an iconic
american character
and coming from new zealand i thought
the fans because the fans of archie are
crazy
and um yeah
and i think they have like a certain
ownership over it and for a new
zealander to come in and play this
character i thought maybe i'd get a bit
of stick for it but
it's been good yeah i mean that's
reaction to the hairband
uh yeah it's amazing
the thing is it was done well they've
been like a bad you know
nasty gnarly guy yeah it looks fantastic
it looks totally natural
he's meant for him does he have your
seal of approval he does he gets the
stamp of approval from all redheads
on the board of redheads i'm the
president of the board of redheads
of approval he's hiding something that
he's ashamed of
uh something that happened erotic
feelings
why do you always go there
rg and jughead did have a lot of stores
i feel like i don't even know cole
sometimes um
every time we have scenes together we're
yelling at each other
so it'd be good to have like a scene
where we're just mates you know what i
mean like the boys
but as of now i haven't seen any of that
so i feel like we haven't really gotten
many like cheryl and jughead scenes
yeah we can put that on the back burner
for a long time
that's great that the scenes take way
longer now that she's a part of the
circle i'm sorry
are you serious nicole will you ever
partake in any of the music hamilton
i mean if it makes sense for jughead oh
yeah i like that
i don't i didn't really ever have a hard
stance against it i just didn't yes you
did he didn't want to i didn't want to
drop an album for disney when i was a
kid so yeah
i didn't want to sing that was a soft
set but i mean for me
you know if if if jughead getting on
stage in front of a crowd feels like
uh it's in line with his character then
then totally fine
but he's fundamentally an anti-social
kid so it doesn't really seem like
something you would do
have you been suggesting anybody that
you would like to play your little
sister
dylan was a big one
you read my mind yeah but he said no i
mean
it was a scheduling conflict hey jay
what would you like to think of archie
this one
what would i like to see for archie
some clothes on i'd like to see him do a
bit more writing
and i think that's kind of the route
we're going to be taking it sounds a lot
like he's going to be more of a season
one jughead
your hair has grown larger by the hour
that's because i'm gaining power
riverdale cass thank you so much for
stopping by
hey click that like button and subscribe
below me for more content